hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge watts an lustigerweise
habe ich genau heute geburtstag
so jetzt wo hier ein bisschen dekoriert
haben habe ich mir gedacht ich nehme
meinen geburtstag müssen als aufhänger
für dieses video
denn als ich vor 19 jahren geboren wurde
wurde dabei auch festgehalten welche
augenfarbe oder welche haarfarbe ich zum
beispiel habe meine eltern konnten
damals keinen wirklichen einfluss darauf
nehmen
aber vielleicht ändert sich das bald in
der zukunft mit der nächsten eltern
generation genetische modifizierung
macht's möglich
was wäre wenn ich mein kind nach meinen
vorlieben gestalten können
vor wenigen wochen haben sie es
geschafft chinesische wissenschaftler
konnten zum allerersten mal überhaupt
menschliche embryos genetisch verändern
und seit sie ihre ergebnisse
veröffentlicht haben steht die welt der
wissenschaft kopf nun das klarzustellen
es handelt sich hierbei um embryos die
nicht mehr zu einem menschen
heranwachsen konnten aber was ist
eigentlich passiert
die wissenschaftler haben erfolgreich
eine kleine sequenz aus der dns der
embryos entfernt dieser kleine teil der
dns ist für eine tödliche blutkrankheit
verantwortlich wenn die embryos nun zu
einem echten menschen heran gewachsen
wären dann wären diese menschen immun
gegen diese krankheit gewesen um das
hinzukriegen haben die wissenschaftler
aus china eine neuartige technik namens
chris benutzt es klingt erstmal ziemlich
böse basiert aber auf einen vorgang aus
der natur ähnlich wie bakterien sich vor
viren schützen wird hier mit hilfe eines
enzyms der teil des dns codes
herausgeschnitten
der für die krankheit verantwortlich ist
das simple herausschneiden aus der dns
ging auch schon vorher nur fehlte bisher
immer ein messer das klein genug war und
vor allem präzise genug war um den teil
der dns zu entfernen der wichtig war
ohne andere wichtige teile des codes
überhaupt zu berühren die nun
angewendete technik soll aber für alle
arten von zellen funktionieren sogar für
stammzellen und laut der wissenschaftler
sei es in der zukunft potenziell sogar
möglich nicht nur krankheiten zu
entfernen sondern auch attribute wie
intelligenz und attraktivität zu
steigern
viele andere wissenschaftler warnen
davor mit der genetischen veränderung
von menschen zu experimentieren
manche fordern sogar dass temporäre
verbot von chris byrd bis wir besser
verstehen was wir da eigentlich tun denn
im moment wird nicht immer der richtige
dns schrank entfernt manchmal werden
auch andere teile der dns heraus
geschnitten oder verändert das führt
nicht nur dazu dass die krankheit
vielleicht doch auftreten könnte es kann
auch sein dass durch diesen fehler neue
krankheiten entstehen von denen wir
bisher noch gar nicht zu wissen aber gut
um fair zu sein muss man dazu sagen dass
wir immer noch am anfang stehen und
natürlich noch wenig wissen
und wie ist die geschichte oft gezeigt
hat ist es nur eine frage der zeit bis
wir auch diese wissenschaft irgendwann
besser verstehen werden
und genau deshalb ist es unglaublich
wichtig dass wir uns als gesellschaft so
früh wie möglich mit den ethischen
folgen auseinandersetzen sollten wir
wirklich unsere eigenen gene verändern
ich meine selbst wenn wir sicher sein
können dass nicht nach mehreren
generationen doch noch probleme
auftreten wollen wir wirklich in einer
welt leben in der jeder perfekt ist klar
ist es fairer nachgewiesenermaßen haben
es attraktive person immer leichter
einen job zu bekommen
aber ist es noch menschlich wenn jeder
typ auf der straße ein super typ ist
eine welt voller gewinner das potenzial
dieser methode ist natürlich riesig
krankheiten schon vor der geburt eines
menschen ausschließen und damit
vielleicht sehr viele leben retten und
mit den jahrzehnten von forschung und
experimenten können wir uns vielleicht
sogar sicher sein dass wir nichts
anderes wichtiges kaputt machen aber
können wir dann wirklich bei den
krankheiten aufhören
wie lange wird es dauern bis ich einen
schurkenstaat seine eigenen
supersoldaten zusammen mixed oder promis
ihre kinder schon vorzeitig ein bisschen
aufpeppen
in vielerlei hinsicht kann man unsere
jetzige situation mit dem schaf dolly
vergleichen dem ersten geklonten
säugetier
ich denke wir werden in den nächsten
jahren noch viel über dieses thema
sprechen und ich bin extrem gespannt was
eure meinung zu dem thema ist schreibt
auf jeden fall unten in die kommentare
und erwähnenswert finde ich noch dass
das fachmagazin science dass wir hier
bei pixum ja sehr häufig und sehr gerne
zitieren sich aus ethischen gründen
geweigert hat die studie zu
veröffentlichen wenn ihr von mir noch
ein geburtstagsgeschenk haben wollt dann
klickt auf den ersten link unten in der
video beschreibung da klickt ihr ein
kostenloses hörbuch von audible komplett
gratis keine versteckten kosten
und ansonsten viel spaß damit und wenn
ihr noch mehr von mir sehen wollt dann
findet ihr hier unten die letzten beiden
folgen von vielen dank fürs zuschauen
und ich geh jetzt feiern